oh
here we are i bet this brings back some
fond memories huh
last time i was here i was getting
wheeled out on a stretcher
[Music]
not that memory throughout history
humans have had a primal instinct to
compete to dominate
and through these battles an unexpected
camaraderie was born
this is a story about my group of
friends
all right boys here we go the buddy
games are back we're gonna play for a
150
000 bucks we'll play your high-stakes
[ __ ] but that was not easy to scrape up
i gave obama a hand job for 30 dollars
i'm giving you the early bird special oh
expand on that no i'm not going did you
want to smell my hand no no
probably not kicking off this year's
event get a girl to buy you a drink got
it easy enough you can do that
without [ __ ] your pants first
laxatives man
hey can you buy me a drink i live in my
van what no
i'll try your box for a week you like
vodka
yeah two wet ones
[Music]
is it injured because it doesn't feel
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
enter the dragon what
he sensed his fear
that was intense
goddamn dude
you